It's like this big box. This is what it looks like.
And so this is between me and the whales,
and at times that feels like a block between you and reality.
Is there a difference when it's just your phone?
Last year, I went to Uluru in Central Australia,
which is this massive rock that towers over the desert.
This is sacred land to Anangu,
who are the Aboriginal people from this area
and the traditional owners of the land.
There are particular spots in Uluru that you cannot photograph professionally,
because they are culturally sensitive,
equivalent to sacred scripture to Anangu.
So because of this, most of my photographs are from either far away, like this one,
or from specific angles in the park.
You could say that some of the most interesting and beautiful visuals in Uluru
are located in these sensitive areas,
but the request not to photograph them is an explicit and direct invitation
to learn more about the land, its importance and its people.
Isn't that what we should be doing anyway?
So my visit to Uluru quickly became not about me
but about connecting with the place.
Ironically and unsurprisingly,
I have found that presence and connection
also happens to make for more compelling images.
We can probably all point to social media
as being a good place to share the images from our travels and from our lives.
We not only share pieces of the world that we have seen
but also parts of our day-to-day experiences.
And if we're applying intentionality to the photos we take,
then hopefully we're sharing intentionally too.
For me, allowing people to see pieces of my story and my perspective online
has reminded me that I'm not alone.
It's helped me build support and community
to do the same for others.
Let me be clear:
I am not trying to discourage you from taking photos.
Even if thousands of people have been to whatever exact location
and taken whatever exact photo,
I encourage you to get out and create too.
The world needs every voice and perspective,
and yours is included.
But what I'm trying to show you is that the phone or camera
doesn't have to stay out all the time.
What I'm trying to encourage you to do
is to put it away, just for a moment --
a moment for you.
So let's go back to Mesa Arch,
the way that the rock glows orange
and the lovely layers of blue in the background.
What if the next time you were somewhere amazing,
you couldn't bring your camera or phone?
What if you were not allowed to take any pictures at all?
Would it feel like a limitation?
Or would it feel like a relief?
So what can we do?
Well, the next time you feel the impulse to take out your camera or phone,
or, in my case, once you realize you have already pulled it out --
(Laughter)
First: stop.
Pause.
Take a deep breath.
Look around. What do you notice?
Are you experiencing this moment with someone else?
Remember that this moment only comes once.
Photography can be part of a beautiful experience.
Just don't let it be a block between you and reality.
Be intentional,
and don't lose a beautiful, irreplaceable memory,
because you were too focused on getting the shot.
Thank you.
(Applause)